when you bake at home think about the
people that you are serving food to
the people that you love the people you
want to please with your food
[Music]
perfect
the first contact you have with the food
is always a visual contact
my pastries are like a silent film you
have to be seduced by it
that's amazing i'm going to teach you
the building blocks of pastry with a
simple recipe make something beautiful
you have to learn to really master a
croissant i call it the omelet of pastry
it should feel super fluffy and light i
look at this honeycomb this air pocket
flakes all over this is a really
beautiful croissant
i think it's very important to have
everything in front of you before you
start doing anything
when you whisk something everything is
in the wrist draw an eight
with your whisk and then draw zero you
repeat this forever
[Music]
history is very precise and scientific
you have to measure
prepare plan less than three seconds
[Music]
being creative is everything
super smooth shiny you can see the glaze
that's been done properly
when you look into it you can see your
reflection
[Music]
you can be creative as well being
creative is also connecting with people
think about who you are serving food to
baking can be
daunting you should never be intimidated
anyone can be a great baker with a good
teacher
i'm dominic ansel and this is my master
class
you